why are the 4th wave feminists much much
worse in their arguments a much more
vociferous and bitter and ugly then
people were 100 years ago may have
something legitimate to say about this I
say this in the madness of crowds why
why latest uneasy coats come across as
far more bitter and negative about
America than James Baldwin in this
current shutdown crisis the issues that
dominated the headlines the past few
years now seem trivial in comparison
intersectionality reusable plastic bags
gender pronouns culture war is obsessed
with inequality sewing division among us
as the issues become more and more niche
in what was up until three months ago
the richest most prosperous time to be
alive in America Douglas Murray
willingly and enthusiastically dances
over these land mines as a British
political author and journalist in his
new book the madness of crowds gender
race and identity Douglass exposes the
grotesque nature of finding meaning in
one's identity he explores the ways
social media news universities and so on
drive the wedge and sell social justice
which leads him to ask his readers to
look around and ask themselves is this
the society in 111 Douglass has been a
contributor to The Spectator for twenty
years an associate editor for the last
eight he writes regularly for outlets
including the Wall Street Journal Sunday
Times National Review and more and his
previous book the strange death of
Europe immigration identity and Islam
spent 20 weeks on The Sunday Times
bestseller list in our conversation we
discussed that books analysis of the
full-on destruction of Europe if
everyone is a nationalist during a
pandemic what conservatives in the UK
have taken for granted and what the
European perception of President Trump
has been missing
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm joined today by Douglas Murray and I
have a bunch of the special bonus
questions just for Douglas and you can
hear those special questions when you
become a member over a daily wire comm
slash subscribe
you're gonna hear all of the bonus
questions and his answers over there
join the club
daily wire.com slash subscribe Douglas
Murray thanks so much for joining the
ben shapiro show sunday special it's
great to see you from afar so let's
let's begin with what is the situation
with Kovan 19 abroad so obviously in the
united states all attention has been on
how the united states has been handling
this thing there's been a lot of
controversy over in britain about the
original handling of Cova 19 and then
these sort of shift from a Swedish model
to a more lockdown model another opening
up the lockdown what exactly was the
chain of events that occurred in Britain
well first it's great to be with you Ben
and so we can do it in person but yes
I'm here in the UK and we're having very
much the same conversations you're
having there ID'd the same conversations
that are going on in every country at
the moment it's true that the British
government changed its tactics early on
its strategy but by and large the
government has had good public support
for this there are some interesting
developments that have been going on I
mean the first of them is the fact that
it seems that the earliest projections
particularly from Imperial College of
what were expected to be the mortality
rates as it's nothing like it that's
occurred so far and I suppose the
fallout from that here already is the
debate that's now emerging between the
people saying well it was never going to
be like that and the ones were saying
well it's only like that because of the
precautions that we've all taken by
locking ourselves in our houses you know
it's it's it's it's strange here in the
UK I have to say because we don't really
have the pressure that is clearly
mounting there in the u.s. of people
saying look we just this isn't
sustainable
in fact the polling in the UK suggests a
quite a significant percentage of the
British population quite like lockdown
would like to see it go on they're
saying like 28 percent want it to go on
even if all of the conditions of
government is set for lifting it a met
so I don't know how those twenty eight
percent either they're very scared very
worried or really lazy and love getting
most of their salary without the tedium
of having to go into the
this why do you think that is it's been
fascinating to watch this has turned
very political in the United States
really really quickly and some of that
may be because the United States is such
a large country territorially and
obviously there are vast differences
between New York City and the rest of
the country but has it broken down along
political lines the pressure to to
either lock down or or to and lock down
you sort of suggest that there's been a
lot more consensus about policies why do
you think there is that difference it's
interesting it bridges has been in
recent years seem to be very like
America that is we've been repeatedly
told that we're a divided society and
divided along specific political lines
now in the UK those lines were pro or
anti brexit and of course that pretty
much was solved at the end of January
this year when Britain left the European
Union finally so we've we've got a
fairly United Front
in this particular crisis at the moment
in a way that I think America doesn't
because in America not least often
because you got an election coming up
this crisis seems to me to be being seen
inevitably through the prism of what do
you think about Donald Trump and do you
want him reelected so mercifully we
haven't had quite that sort of clear
divide that you've got going on there
between people who would like to use the
coronavirus to get Donald Trump out of
the White House and those who'd like to
use it to keep him in but there are the
certainly the beginnings of a type of
line emerging a competition emerging
should we say which is the same one that
we're going to have everywhere which is
the very significant tension that is
emerging between the people saying we
have to keep people particularly the
elderly who are most vulnerable to the
virus safe and those saying we just
can't go on with this forever the
British government is currently
borrowing at levels that are higher than
any time since the Second World War
and some of us myself included think
that this is very unwise for a range of
reasons one of which is the point of
running up the debt of the Second World
War was because this was something that
was never going to be needed again
something it would never happen again
we hoped I don't think anyone could say
that with this virus I think we are
mounting up unbel
lievable levels of debt and doing so to
tackle something which is quite like it
happened again certainly in our
lifetimes when you look at again that
political debate one of the things that
I wonder is whether that exposes not so
much the difference between left and
right trends nationally as the
difference between perhaps the American
right in the British right meaning that
the European right has been for a very
long time a lot more friendly to the
idea of a massive social safety net even
the the Conservative Party in Britain
isn't talking about dismantling the
National Health Service in the United
States obviously the Republican Party
has been very much against the federal
government getting deeply involved in
the economy providing the sorts of
financial guarantees that the European
governments do fairly regularly right
does that really expose the difference
between sort of the differences between
European right and American right yeah I
think that is true the the British and
European right long ago made their peace
with the welfare state in a way which I
think isn't isn't the case obviously in
the u.s. the same extent the
Conservative Party at the moment I mean
the is in a very insane position it has
become the party of the National Health
Service now the Labour Party the
left-wing party here in the UK has tried
for years to win elections by saying
every time you've only got X number of
days left to save the NHS you know if
you vote conservative they will
dismantle privatize or whatever the NHS
I've heard that all my life I've got
three days to save the NHS two years one
day two hours that's what they always
say and here we see this incredible
moment where the concern is not only
been more than adequately funding the
NHS but but cannot possibly be accused
of being ante the National Health
Service at the moment you know every
minister turns up the press conferences
with an NHS badge on their lapel I mean
there they've got it written on them and
and so I think that critique of the left
is going to be hard to sustain it has an
obvious down downfall doesn't it which
is when the Conservative Party simply
has to doing anything that the NHS asks
for its satisfy every demand because it
becomes so much uh-uh and hoc to it now
I mean there are there are problems here
because the NHS does some things well
things badly you know it's a service not
a deity but under this government and in
this crisis inevitably it's become a
sort of deity and and that's gonna have
problems down the road so in in your
book the strange death of Europe you
talk about all of these sort of
fragmenting elements that have been
happening in Europe for years and it
feels like the pandemic has really
exacerbated a lot of these problems
obviously there were there serious debt
problems in a lot of countries in Europe
before this the idea of sort of a
unified economic bloc didn't make a lot
of sense when Germany was footing the
bill for Greece and when it comes to
immigration obviously there were serious
underlying problems with the idea that
every country was gonna have completely
permeable borders there's been this sort
of talk in the United States that
everybody's a socialist during a
pandemic but what really seems like is
everybody's a nationalist during a
pandemic oh yeah well it's both of those
things isn't it what seems so to me
I mean everyone's in favor of massive
spending and of shutting all the borders
I mean I covered the migration crisis of
2015 you know firsthand traveled very
widely across the continent and the
continents people were coming from and
you know in 2015 when hundreds of
thousands of people were pouring into
Europe illegally you know I used to
think why why isn't this able to be
stopped and people tell me you've got
you've got to understand we live in a
globalized world and it's not possible
to shut borders this is simply the
modern world I remember one of the
former French ministers saying to me
there's nothing that can be done and so
you can imagine that it with a certain
amount of well Glee I suppose that I
noticed people like Justin Trudeau
shutting all the borders of Canada
having told us for years that you know
open borders were just a thing that we
all lived within their only upsides and
then then the coronavirus comes along
and it turns out even Justin Trudeau can
shut the borders at a moment's notice
this happened across Europe is something
that we were told wasn't possible with
the immigration crisis was certainly
possible with the corona crisis but
there are lots of tensions in Europe
that this has opened up the most
interesting to my mind is the
north/south divide which always goes on
one of the great I mean obviously we in
Britain have now left the European Union
it always seems to me slightly rude
to criticize a club you've just resigned
from but some of us who were always
predicts for the EU used to say that the
fundamental problem particularly of
monetary union was the idea that you
could meld German and Italian fiscal
habits or Greek and German bookkeeping
and you know one of the fascinating
intentions has just broken that again
over this coronavirus which is this
north/south divide where the the South
once again is absolutely the brunt of
Italy in Spain that first had the worst
mortality figures in this virus and
having been lectured for years as those
countries were by the north telling them
that there needed to be greater
integration and a greater pooling of
sovereignty what happens when the
coronavirus hits but both France and
Germany suddenly become completely
protectionist over the export of masks
oxygen and other necessities and you can
imagine on the southern European
countries particularly Italy looks at
this has been told three years this is
precisely the sort of a thing that the
EU has been set up to avoid and the two
countries that lectured them hardest
France and Germany turn out when needed
to be just as nationalistic as the
countries they had been attacking all of
these years you know I mean a particular
moment in macro and just lemarchal who
have loved attacking people for being
nationalists in Central and Eastern
Europe love attacking people for being
protectionists in these countries but it
turns out that there is something which
makes them do exactly the same and
actually a lot more so - second I want
to ask you about the future of Europe
and then about the the future of
specific states within the European
Union and the future but we'll get to
that in just one second but first I just
want to say thank you to our advertisers
here at the Ben Shapiro show Sundays
special we certainly appreciate them
being part of our show every week and we
appreciate you patronizing them they
appreciate that as well so let's talk
about how you protect your online data
and in the time since I started using
expressvpn hacking methods have grown
ever more sophisticated I'm sure many of
you are working from home
these days and you don't have your IT
department to protect you from an online
threat so it's important you take
measures to protect yourself that's why
I recommend using Express VPN for the
best online protection possible I've
been talking about expressvpn on the
show for so long you already understand
why encrypting your network data is
important but some of you still have not
acted why well maybe thinking security
threats don't affect you personally but
not using Express VPN is like leaving
your front door unlocked every time you
go out sure nothing might happen for
years but when a break-in does occur it
can be devastating one of the easiest
ways to secure your internet data is
with Express at VPN you click one button
on your computer or your smartphone you
are now protected so here's the question
why haven't you gone and just done this
yet visit my special link right now
expressvpn comm slash man get next four
three months of expressvpn for free
protect your internet today with the VPN
I've been trusting for years to keep my
data safe you cannot afford to leave
your data expose not in this environment
go to express VPN calm slash man again
that's expressive VPN calm slash man get
next four three months for free
I've expressed VPN calm when you go to
express VPN calm slash been so Douglas
let's talk about the future of the
European Union they don't wanna get to
sort of analyzing the differences within
the European Union so in your book you
talk about some of the animating
differences in the EU that we're leading
to its breakup even before the the
pandemic really exacerbated those
divides so you've talked about sort of
the the fiscal differences and cultural
differences what do you think are the
chief factors that are leading to the
breakup of the great European dream the
post-world War two idea that Europe was
going to be sort of the United States of
Europe going forward well I think the
central tension has always been the same
which is that many countries including
Britain at the time believed in a
trading bloc believe that it was
sensible that instead of having dozens
of countries each competing with each
other and the wider world they should
group together and and and and in this
70s and take about without that seemed
too many people including people on the
right to be a fairly sensible policy the
problem started to emerge particularly
in the 90s particularly 90s with the
Maastricht Treaty which is the moment
when everything changes because the
Maastricht Treaty is a time when the EU
says that it is dedicated to ever closer
Union the problem with ever closer union
is that it shows you the direction of
it says it says we will not be content
until this is one sovereign unified
continent nation and of course the
problem is there are lots of people who
are vaguely supportive of aspects of the
EU project European project who still
want to be citizen to a country and
still believe that there are a range of
things from security to taxation and
more fiscal matters that should be
decided at the national level
I mean Greece in recent years would have
had a lot easier a time if it had not
been tied to the to the promises that it
ended up having to make to the to the
Germans and to Brussels in the wake of
the 2008 crisis if if Greece had just
gone on gone off alone and had the
drachma it probably wouldn't have had
the severity of oppression its had in
the last decade so there are lots of
reasons why people were were worried it
wasn't just you know nationalism of some
kind of just lots of reasons why people
in each of the countries thought that
the EU project should stop at a certain
stage that there was a there was a stage
where the public became uncomfortable
there was a stage where basically the EU
became a lecturing body to the continent
rather than a representative body of
some kind or a convening body and that
happened from the 90s and all of the
tensions that have arisen since have
arisen basically from that one tension
why can't the EU stop why can't I say
this is what we are and this is what
works why does it always have to pull
sovereignty more and more and and that's
attention is just on every issue still
playing out now within Europe obviously
there are very large national
differences in Europe and in Eastern
Europe you have very nationalistic
states with authoritarian tendencies in
Western Europe you have states that seem
to in many cases have lost their their
way we talked with Rostow that last week
on the sunday special and he was talking
about the sort of lack of will that
seems to have been engendered in Western
civilisation is happening in the United
States he suggests that Europe has
become decadent where do you think are
sort of the virile centers for Europe if
there
going to be countries in Europe that are
sort of if you have to map trajectories
which countries have an upward
trajectory and which ones look like they
are at a blowing or or falling that's a
very different question to answer I mean
until we were all confined to our homes
and can travel there anywhere I was
different European country pretty much
every week over recent years I've I
travel and it continued to travel very
widely even after finishing the strange
death of Europe and because I find the
developments across the continent
fascinating one of the reasons why it's
so fascinating is because individual
countries you can see being pulled in
different directions at the same time
let me give an example France for
instance has a particularly bad I think
the worst in Europe where a record on
intubation France has a larger
population of immigrant background than
any other country in the EU it is it
massively mucked up its integration
programs after the movement of peoples
in large numbers from North Africa in
particular as you know if you go to
Marseille or Paris into the center of
the city is - it's beautiful chocolate
box a Dilek romantic place and you go to
the suburbs where the prisons or the
locals don't go and you see this totally
other world it's it's I I use the
example in strange death of Europe if
you go to Paris you have the two forms
of metro you have the Paris metro and
then you have the RER the REI is the
deep underneath the metro line that goes
out to the banya of the suburbs and you
get do if you get to show the goal you
you use that now the fascinating thing
to me is you go on the metro that
there's more shallow one that just just
stops you offered you know short
intervals in the center of Paris and
it's a beautiful chic Parisian life
everyone's beautiful everything seems
wonderful get on the AR AR that goes out
further and you see a totally different
world and one that the prisons in my
mind deliberately avoid the stations
where these these are AR lines stop I
like little bits of volcano you see the
people from the burner will come in and
sand congregate around that station
I give it as an analogy not to beat up
on the French good pastime as that is
for many people but just to point out
this is a particularly visible form of
failed integration it's just it's just
more visible in almost anywhere else now
why do I give the example of France not
just for that reason but because
simultaneously France has an
extraordinary strength that I don't
think almost any other country in Europe
has it has an extraordinarily strong
sense of itself it has the role of the
president in France by the way and I
don't particularly nob servation is the
president of France has more power than
almost any other leader you can think of
in the Democratic world I mean what the
French president can do you know ban all
public gatherings ban protests this has
been done scores and scores of time in
the present president's time alone so
the reason I mention this is because
simultaneously you have this country
with with I think worst integration
history but one of the strongest senses
of itself I mean you know one of the
will take one of the key years in recent
years when you have is in 2015-2016 you
have earned with the rise of Isis you
see in in the in in one year in France
at the beginning of the year all the
most renowned secularists in France a
staff of Charlie Hebdo are gunned down
in their offices by two extremists and
at the end of the year a priest is
beheaded had his throat slit at the
altar of his church while saying mass
outside Rouen now I tell you this
because what society could go through a
year like that
and with a massive matter Clara attacks
and much more and hold together with its
sense of itself that could have
everybody from the secularists to the
priests attacked and could still hold
the society together yes so there's an
extraordinary complexity of trying to
analyze European countries because of
precisely that sort of that sort of dual
problem going on at the same time a
terrible terrible challenge and a deep
well that can be but can be drawn up
that I wouldn't certainly wouldn't
ignore well one of the things that you
talk about there is is the society
census of themselves and it feels like
in America also you know we're having
trouble deciding exactly what our sense
of our self is in in Europe it used to
be that one of those senses was
religious in nature obviously Europe has
moved in an overwhelmingly secular
direction and at least at the same time
birth rates have concomitant ly fallen
in Muslim immigration into Europe has
concomitant ly increased I so it seems
like religious identity is on the way
and it seems like until the past decade
or so nationalist identity was
dramatically on the way and with the
with the rise of the EU and the feeling
that we had moved into the post-national
world and so the question becomes for a
lot of these nations what exactly is the
animating feature of shared identity
what exactly is shared anymore we're
experiencing this in the United States
as well do you think that there's a
renewed sense of shared identity in
places like Britain and is that really
what's what what is driving a lot of the
separation ISM inside the EU that an
attempt to derive a shared identity
again because it turns out the
transnationalism is not an identity
globalization's not an identity
secularism isn't actually an identity
that you need something more than that
in order to create a shared polity yes I
mean there are relatively few ways as
you know that we can go here as human
beings outside of the immediate family
structure and religion is one of the
very few and one of the best and
national belonging is certainly one of
the one of the only other alternative
and national belonging has been seen in
Europe as being purely a vice in recent
decades basically since the end of the
Second World War and there's that that's
because of a very simplistic analysis
which caught on which said well
nationalism caused two world wars and
therefore if we get rid of nation-states
we'll get rid of nationalism there
therefore ergo we will get rid of war
well there are many problems with this
overwhelmingly common viewpoint
one of them is of course before Europe
was riven by the conflicts of the
nation-states we were riven by the Wars
of Religion something which I think is
perfectly possible we could return to in
our own lifetimes so it's
not the case of nationalism or national
identity is the only cause of war a
second problem by the way of that
critique is it it completely fails to
notice that it's not nationalism that
caused those waters it was German
expansionism
in both cases will be the second time
under under Nazi ideology and you know
I've said several times most recently a
speech in Rome that that I think we know
where nationalism can go wrong but
everything can go wrong I mean love
cause the Trojan Wars love can go wrong
everything can be perverted used to
terrible ends and cause and bring about
catastrophe but it doesn't mean you
don't deal in that element at all you
know religion can cause Wars yes do you
want to ban religion no and how would
you go about that these are that this is
a problem of the post-war identification
of nationalism as being the sole cause
of conflict is it is it nationalism can
also be national belonging can also be
one of the most important sources of
meaning that people find in their lives
and as the late Roger Scruton described
it though the widest application of the
first-person plural the widest
application of the use of the we you
know the way you can where you can feel
a pride in things you yourself may not
directly have contributed to but also
can connect and spread that around to
others and that that this is that you
can feel belonging even if it's just
because of your adjacency to people now
I think that as I say that that what we
what we did in Europe was to essentially
try to get rid of national belonging as
a legitimate source of meaning
we lost religion around the same time
we've been losing it for 150 years in
Europe and you know that that's a very
interesting subject in itself but the
problem is has left us with is what I
described in a strange death of Europe
in one chat as the sense that the story
has run out and this is I think very
pertinent to American viewers as well
because
what this means is that you you know
that you're living in the embers of
something which you yourself cannot
Kindle but you like the afterglow you
know you like what warmth there is but
you have no intention to tend the fire
and and and there are many many deep
problems that come from this which I
which I explore in that book one of
which is this thing to do with religion
which is whether or not for sort of put
it in the Hegelian like term is whether
or not it's an exhausted force or not
my own belief is that it isn't and and
and that we should think about it and
deal with it more deeply and more
seriously than we've been willing to
that you know religion isn't just
something like a sort of charity event
you do you know and it's not a hobby you
know it's it's not something you could
choose to do or not like tennis or golf
and and so I think and I think that one
other thing I'd add to that which is
that there's a very deep issue which
America is going through which we went
through before you which is this
fundamental question of who are we and
in Europe we've started and this
includes in Britain although things like
the brexit vote are definitely an
attempt to sort of push back against
this but in recent years in Europe we've
basically come to this place where we've
decided we are basically nothing and
we're not interested and we have nothing
of our own of interest other than that
we can provide a sort of convening space
for the world to meet and bring us ideas
and cuisine and culture and and and and
music and things that we in Europe of
course have never had and and and that
therefore we are as it were the like
like the paint that you need to add
colors to that isn't yet a color itself
but with this with this non thing now it
seems to me that in America you have a
version of that as well that's been
coming along in recent years and there
is a backlash to it which we had again
first which is you start to redefine
yourself in increasingly crass terms so
in Europe and in Brit
in recent years we've had this thing of
who are we and here and you come up with
things like we are we are about niceness
kindness or Fairplay anything well sure
I mean all those things really good I
mean nobody actually says they're anti
any of those things even even the Saudis
don't don't say that they're actually
against the niceness for fairness you
know everyone thinks they're for
fairness and decency you know I've just
got different definitions of it but but
but but that's the sort of thing we've
come down to and I think that it's
because in Europe as in America we've
basically wanted to pretend that a
highly unusual political and religious
settlement is the norm is that
non-colored pain and that you know it's
just you know it whenever you shake
about the human species and give it long
enough it always looks like Amsterdam
and it's just so fantastically crass
because the people who think this is so
parochial they've never been anywhere
they've never traveled anywhere they
clearly have no recognition of the fact
that what we have in Europe and what you
have in America is unbelievably unusual
in historical geographical terms and
that you know it's as likely that the
world turns out looking like Mogadishu
as it does that it ends up looking like
Boston and you didn't get to Boston
instead of Mogadishu just by chance or
hanging around long enough or having
enough diversity parades it is that
mentality that we've seen in the United
States as well and it's it's something
that I've found really troubling and you
see it in this sort of study of both
American and European history this idea
that when something truly terrible
happens in the West that it is unique to
the West but when something good happens
it to the West then it is a world
achievement we saw this with regard to
the moon landing where people in the
West are saying well that was a real
achievement by humanity but when it
comes to things like slavery well that
that is unique to the West that is a yes
it's a it's a horrible sin that was
committed by the West also existed in
every society for all of human time and
that isn't that isn't a justification
for slavery in the West it is to suggest
that what makes the West difference is
the stuff that actually makes the West
to print
it is not the stuff that is common to
all humanity yeah the interesting thing
was that we abolished slavery I mean
plenty of places didn't bother to learn
your places still have it going on now
so say yes III think by the way Ben you
put this this particular issue points to
a very important thing I think we all
have to be able to think about which is
when people raise these things are they
raising them when they say look at your
history of colonialism or look at your
history of slavery are they raising them
as critics or as enemies and I think
this is one of the most quote important
questions to address it reminds me of
something that the Jeanne Kirkpatrick
said around the time of Vietnam she said
I didn't doubt that America had the
opportunity to be better but in order to
be better it had to survive it had to
continue and and you had then as we have
now a certain cohort of people who don't
want America to continue as it is don't
want Britain to continue as this don't
want Europe to continue the way it is
and and and I hear that all the time and
I don't think it's called out often
enough that when somebody says you know
you have nothing but the original sin as
I call it in strange death of Europe the
original sin of of of settler
colonialism or slavery or empire and and
my way you can do that everywhere even
countries in Europe like Sweden that had
no empires are sort of you know like
melded into the guilty Empire
post-colonial guilt parade and so when
people do that and they say that's all
you are
I just think we should turn out and say
that is such an unfair estimation of our
societies I mean every every country on
earth I've ever been to has good things
and bad things to be said about them but
when you only focus on the bad you know
if you said that I know a country in
like Greece or something if you said
Greece has never done anything it's
never produced anything it's just it's
just it just robs people or something
people say this is an unfair it seems
like a weird fatigue what have you got
against the Greeks we'd know that that
was what was going on because this
wouldn't be a fair
of the country as it would be if you
talked about any country in Africa the
Far East the Middle East or anywhere
else and and that's what we've been
dealing with we've been dealing with in
all of our countries in recent years
enemies people who hate our societies
don't want them to continue as they are
in any recognizable forms want to
completely transform them but would like
us to pretend that they are merely
critics who just want a couple of tweaks
and mildly change us and and that's just
not the case it's it's so wildly unfair
the way in which a couple of generations
now have been lied to about what our
societies are well this is automatic so
some of the stuff you talked about in
your newest book the madness of crowds
because as we've dissolved some of the
larger kind of societal forces that bind
us as we've dissolved religion as we've
dissolved nationalism tribalism has
sprung up in its most basic forms you've
seen people reverting to almost more
basic form smaller form smaller group
forms of identity in opposition to that
larger blank space that you've been
talking about and you talked about this
in terms of what we see online the
social media mobbing the the search for
identity in in finding people that we
can get together and attack this is the
search for identity in race in gender
and and how that really is tearing us
apart yes I mean after doing after doing
strange death of Europe and writing
about immigration Islam and
multiculturalism I thought what are that
what are the remaining landmine issues
that I can like merrily dance over and
jump on I thought I thought I know and
in fact I quite like occasionally and I
speaker those it's being a talk to the
university at a while ago in them is a
very smart young student interviewing me
and about the madness of crowds and he
said I just like for the audience again
idea of what would I just like to read
out the title page of Douglass's new
book and he read out he's a gay women
race trans
he looked out at the audience and I
looked out of them and they all just had
their eyes and then we all burst out
laughing because you know every single
one of them and I can't deny that I sort
of enjoy seeing these so you know
ridiculously over complicated issues
that people are terrified about I can't
deny it I quite enjoy you know being the
person you know one of the people who
says you know the Emperor's got no
clothes or in this case although the
Emperor is a total fraud an idiot so I
decided to do them all one by one and
and love doing so I mean I also by the
way I just have a great time on this
because it's just I mean a lot of it is
like shooting fish in a barrel because
you're dealing with AI I thought by the
way I should stress that when I started
looking deeply into the whole issues of
intersectionality and all that sort of
thing I did what I always do which is I
go back to the fundamental text the
foundational literature what are the
philosophical basis for this you know
well what's the stuff we contend with
first and I have to say I thought with
this that you know the identity politics
movement which is is not just racing
through all of our societies but racing
through business in all of our societies
I mean it's not just government that's
absorbed this stuff is it's it's you
know fortune 500 companies we've all got
diversity outreach you know officers and
HR departments which are the only
thriving part of the business and and
and and so I thought well at least if
we've done this if we've rolled this out
everywhere there must be some serious
thought behind it and I was just
flabbergasted by how little of it there
was it was it is small insignificant
texts from the 1970s onwards mainly from
American universities it has to be said
who just searched things they don't even
prove them they just assert things the
foundational text the one of them of
intersectionality is unpacking the
knapsack it's just a couple of pages of
assertions which are all wrong by the
way provably so and and and now you've
got you know now
several decades of people have gone to
universities particular America and and
become totally unemployable is
completely useless to society at large
by studying these things as if as if
they exist as if they're real as if
they've been agreed upon and so by
dating them one by one one of the things
I wanted to do was to help deprogram
particularly young Americans and young
Europeans who had been violently badly
programmed who had been told that their
society is something which their society
isn't and had been told that the way out
is something which is catastrophic Lee
obviously not a way out you know find
meaning in womanhood
Wow deep find meaning and being gay make
it your entire life you know you know
like only listen to gay music and read
gay texts and and and and we're gay this
is pathetic and it's the same I think on
the race issue I'm he's unbelievable
race baiters he pretend they're anti
races who pretend that people can find
meaning in their life because of their
skin pigmentation I mean it's it's
grotesque and I wanted to push back
against it and to and to say to people
take you to young people don't waste any
more of your life than you have to on
this crap you know find meaning in your
life definitely but don't think you're
gonna get it from your chromosomes it
seems as though one of the fundamental
underlying basis is an unarticulated
assumption and that unarticulated
assumption because if you actually
articulated it it would be obvious what
a problem it is is that all inequalities
are inequities and that therefore if you
are a member of a group that has had
some sort of unequal outcome then that
must be the result of an inequitable
system that the system itself is corrupt
and so what you end up seeing is a lot
of these sort of group identities
directed at precisely the sorts of free
institutions that we normally enjoy and
like so the idea is that a right because
the right is distributed equally is
actually inequitable because not
everybody can take equal advantage of
the right so if you have free-market
economics where everybody has control
over the alienation of their own labor
and resources well that's actually
unequal and unfair because some people
have more resources than others some
people have more intellectual capital
than others the idea is that in the end
what you're shooting for is a sort of
utopian utopian leveling and and if any
group in a and all groups will be
unequal them it doesn't matter how you
staff a room you can distribute them any
way you want if you draw a line down the
middle of it there will be in a
inequalities between the two sides of
the room but the idea here is that if
those if those inequalities exist that
is a problem with the system which leads
to the sort of perennial revolutionary
idea because of course you're never
gonna reach utopia
well quite I mean the first the first
thing is the inputs of avoiding utopian
thinking in general you know
the people as a late friend of mine who
is an expert in this once said the
people who who you can see from the
stare in their eyes as they're coming
towards you with an idea of how you
should live your life and that they know
better than you how you should you
should run a million bloody miles from
these people always always and um that's
that's the first thing the second thing
is I do think there is a a fundamental
issue which doesn't get opened up enough
which you just did which is this a very
instinctive one long before the level of
analysis is is that the sort of world
you want to live in I mean you know I
think the later Irving Kristol and I
enormous the admired said somewhere
years ago in a quote that would have got
him cancelled today he said somewhere
I'm just not I'm not for equality he
said I just I'm not for it in the arts
I'm not for it in sports
I'm just not for it in this world and
and I think there's something in this it
has to be identified because we've been
through iterations of this before do you
want a society do you want a society
where everybody turns out the same or
are you content with a considerable
degree of variation in all sorts of
things I mean we accept the example I
was given we accept the fact that that
height shifts changes a lot and that
edgy has quite an important impact on
your life for some people they're a
certain you know I can I can I could
never have been a basketball player even
if I wanted to I don't think you could
have been either probably been and I'm
sure we've both nurse our wounds for
years on this and we've probably come to
an acceptance by now but you know that
was something that was just that was a
born thing there's nothing either of us
could have done about that
there's a lot of our other factors that
we have no say over very attractive
people a disproportionately likely to be
successful in their lives what do we do
about this we don't know any more than
we do with hype so so the weird thing is
that we've selected a few things to
become obsessive about in the Equality
states but this is foundation and this
is foundational question which
and many people went through in the
early parts of the 20th century as well
one of the things I've been interested
in is why some people had a visceral
reaction against communism a visceral
reaction long before any organized
movements were against it
why did some people just not want it and
broadly speaking the thing I've often
found in people's testimonies from the
time is is that there was an instinctive
revulsion from a certain type of person
who liked to the complexity and oddity
in and variety of the world now this is
this is by the way this is a difficult
thing because of course you'll say well
it's all very well if you're at the top
of the tree to enjoy the variety but I'm
not really saying that what I'm trying
to say is that is that we we probably
have to in order to lead contented or
happy lives reconcile ourselves with
certain things in the world and just as
one reconciles oneself the fact that one
will never be a basketball player so one
has to reconcile oneself to other things
that one can't be and do and the problem
is is one thing built into this which is
is is the discussion we should be having
which we don't have because everyone has
got us stuck on the Equality one and the
discussion we should be having because I
think we could get agreement on right
and left on this is the world we I think
probably could agree on that we want is
one in which nobody is held back from
achieving things because of a
characteristic they have no say over if
they have the competency to achieve it
and I reckon across the left and the
right we could agree on that you know
who doesn't agree with the idea that if
somebody wants to be a physicist and
they happen to be I don't know a woman
or or from an ethnic man not something
that that they shouldn't be able to be a
physicist who wants the women out of six
or black people or minorities out of
fear I mean almost nobody I mean
there'll be some though a few nutters in
America and a few in Europe but but they
have no meaningful voice those people
the rest of us are trying to contend
with a really complex question and we
have a variety of answers
and it's sometimes em compete with each
other but broadly speaking but that is a
different thing from trying to make
society come out completely equal or
equitable as you quite rightly make the
difference and and I just wish that we
actually had that conversation of how
can we make sure that we are societies
with the best possible ladders system in
them rather than this balking moaning
whining
there are things I haven't got in my
life because we can all play that it's
an absolutely unending game that's why I
tell people don't play the privilege
game you can't play it you could you
could discover an Earl in Britain with a
castle of their own who who you would
say that's the most privileged person
and they could have led a hell of a life
you have no idea and and and and as I
say don't don't know I just want to tell
people don't play games that cannot be
won well this does raise the question I
mean you talk about various sorts of
group identity here and I will say it
seems to me that some of the group
identities that have been formed have
been formed responsibly so for example
racial group identity in the United
States in many cases that was formed to
be fair in response to actual racial
oppression so if you say you know I
identify as a black person in the United
States and you're talking about growing
up in the 1960s that makes perfect sense
considering that there was an active
attempt to oppress you and prevent you
from taking part and sort of the ladders
of opportunity they are talking about
but we've we've now shifted the
discussion from you are part of a group
that is being put upon to we're going to
redefine reality so as to create new
groups and this is where you move into
sort of the trans identity issue so now
if you are a man who is a biological
male who believes that you are a woman
we are going to label you as part of a
separate group or actually women and if
people refuse to change the science in
order to meet your expectation of what
you wish you were then you are now an
oppressed group of people just like
black Americans were oppressed in the
1960s by Jim Crow well I'm this several
things to say I mean one is that of
course to say that these things are
going on legitimately now is obviously
not to say there wasn't legitimacy in
the past I mean we immediate who claim
there hasn't been racism or sexism or
homophobia or transphobia and for that
matter but but to say that was that you
know that that has existed in the past
and and to say as a result we should be
fighting this battle not just in the
same manner but actually in a more
vociferous manner in many ways today is
I think one of the reasons why this has
been so divisive I mean
there are things that fourth wave
feminists say that the suffragettes
would never Bream top saying right can
you imagine the suffragettes a century
ago trying to persuade people to give
women the vote
imagine how far they'd have got if
they'd have adopted kill all men as
their slogan he has some fourth my
family said you know like how about how
about the Pankhurst's and others it had
gone around with placards saying men are
trash to use another fourth wave
feminists lo yeah how do you think how
do you how many men do you think they'd
have got on their side in that why are
the 4th wave feminists much much worse
in their arguments and much more
vociferous and bitter and ugly than
people were a hundred years ago and they
have something legitimate to say about
this I say this in the madness of crowds
why why latest uneasy coats come across
as far more bitter and negative about
America than James Baldwin is that the
other writer he was furious when
somebody said you know he wasn't in town
he's going to love to be James Baldwin
he ain't James Baldwin and there's a
reason for and there's a reason in a way
which is at Jake Baldwin among other
things as extraordinary moral
imagination and a consideration about
forgiveness and much more and and I'm
just amazed that that people don't see
that the thing has gone off the rails
because at the stage where things have
never been better they are they are led
by and asked to look up to people who
present the situation as if it's never
been worse and and and you know I think
in a way that just it just vindicates I
think it was it Thomas always said that
that thing that you know we'll rights
movement starting off as a you know
legitimacy legitimate cause becoming a
business and ending up as a racket you
know and this this there's something in
that and but but we are being divided by
these people I think in a way that just
has to called out they they are again
they're making and they're making unfair
claims about our societies and and that
does raise this question of course of
how do you know when to stop
and and I see this I see this all the
time in the in the the LGBT bit of this
which is the only crampon I can claim to
have on the social justice Marathon wall
and I just fascinated by the people who
sort of you know who don't know that
it's over basically you know cuz they've
got a business on the back of it they
got a racket go they want to protect it
you know and they're and they're reduced
to making stuff up making up false
claims and and and exaggerating and
things just cuz maybe otherwise they've
got nothing to do and and and I did
always think this and all of these
social justice movements were in some
way a product of boredom and and
excessive wealth in assess if comfort I
mean it's only if you've got nothing to
complain about you can possibly think
the world would give a damn about a
microaggression
so i wanted to ask you douglas about the
the media in britain versus the media in
the united states because you've written
pretty extensively about the differences
between media in in both countries it's
it's sort of fascinating the united
states obviously we have very broad free
speech rules much broader than the free
speech rules in in britain but at the
same time our media seem to be
significantly more censorious
significantly more welcoming to toward
opinions masquerading as objective
journalism it can you give a sort of a
rundown on on the differences between
british media and american media this
way yeah I mean the UM whenever I'm in
American absorb a lot of American media
it makes me value the BBC which I mean I
have plenty of criticisms of but I do
think that there have been several
things that have happened in America
American media in recent years which
have been very much the negative I mean
I think the main thing is we don't
really have the sort of creations you
have there of people who are for
instance in front of the camera and
expected to explain a worldview for a
willing waiting audience
you know our news programs in particular
mainly because of impartiality rules you
have you have to sort of demonstrate in
partiality which is you know something
weaker but it's there as an aspiration
should we say in British Broadcasting
you can't just go on air and as the
presenter say stuff you have to
counterbalance and much more now of
course there's a problem with that the
problem of the of the balance issue in
British Broadcasting is when you have
and it does happen you have somebody I
don't know for instance it happens a lot
on the Israel one you know you get you
get somebody from you know who's a sort
of moderate leftist analyst of Israeli
affairs and because they recognize you
know the Israeli government you have to
balance them out with you know a Bujji
had a friend years you know the Iraq so
martyrs brigade you know and and so
there's this weird idea that but that
that's the that's the balance of the
debate and and I'm afraid that does
happen on quite a lot of things and it
it it it negatively impacts our
understanding of a range of issues so
there is a problem to this balance a
thing but it does save us from you know
having I wonder I saw recently a the
bond lemon starting his show by just
saying you know it's and he named the
day I think was after all countries
comment to President Trump you know Don
Lemon goes on and he says you know uh
it's whatever the bit is and the
President of the United States is a
racist
you just couldn't you couldn't do that
in British Broadcasting you can't just
you can't just go on air as a presenter
and say stuff and I think that has had a
huge a negative effect in America and I
think the worst thing by the way is the
is this thing of two sides that talk
about each other and never to each other
you know that the left says you know the
thing about conservatives is and the
right says I think that the left is and
I just think it all it'll make things a
lot worse as my own opinion but
I've had this experience personally
actually obviously being from America
and dealing almost solely with American
media when I was on BBC with Andrew Neil
it had no clue who he was and he was
just playing devil's advocate with me or
taking a sceptical point of view I had
no understanding that that's actually
his job is to basically just play the
other side to whomever he's interviewing
and so my core assumption was okay if
somebody is going to speaking to me that
way then it's because they are
representing their actual viewpoint
which is the way that it works in the
United States yes I had that quite early
on in my career I had news night one so
the legendary broadcaster called Jeremy
Paxman
Jeremy Paxman asked me question I did I
sort of fine and he seemed like what I
said and I hug and he laid into the
other guy know that shaking the masacre
sort of Cena vaguely smiling and Jeremy
Paxton and wheeled around to me as I
said what are you smiling at and and
then attacked me on something it was a
good presenters just never on your side
in British TV so with that said let's
turn to British politics in the media
treatment of Boris Johnson so obviously
in the United States the media treatment
of President Trump is 107 percent
negative there has yet to be a
broadcaster in Lausanne in the United
States outside of Fox News who voted for
President Trump who even thinks that
President Trump is a is a breathing
sentient human being as opposed to just
a bad orange giant with with minimal
hand size so how is the media treatment
bin of Boris Johnson in Britain there is
some similarity in in the treatment
there has been an attempt to pretend
that you know Boris Johnson is some
appalling divisive figure and so on it
doesn't actually work I have to say it
one of the reasons is that actually in
conservative terms Boris Johnson is very
liberal and I mean this in a way in in
the American and the British sense of
the understanding of that term his
instincts are deeply liberal in the true
classical sense and he's certainly not
some authoritarian figure he was
enormous ly successful by being elected
twice as the mayor of London in a Labour
voting City
twice took that position for the
Conservative Party so he's obviously
able to attract crossover votes by
leading the brexit campaign the leave
campaign in 2016 and that being
successful a lot of people who did liked
him or had time for him definitely
turned against him but he definitely
took the brunt for a long time with the
negative fallout that did come from
people who are furious about the brexit
vote but by and large I would say that
he enjoys some some better a better
press in the in the UK certainly the
president Trump does in the US and I
think there's there's lots of reasons
that but one of them is just the fact
that the suppurating soar that we've had
under British politics in recent years
has been addressed now I mean I was very
very worried for my country in recent
yes much as I have been from America in
this era because it's this see did seem
to me that having vote having voted to
leave EU in 2016 we had such pushback
all the same things that were done in
the US after the Trump vote you know the
vote is a racist the voters are sexist
the voters are misogynist to vote as a
homophobic they are voting for an
increase in hate crime they're carrying
out hate crimes and much more we had all
of that before it was done in the States
as this massive play back to punish the
voters and and we I worried that that
era was not going to end by actually
taking control of the Conservative Party
finally and leading the UK out of the EU
it seems to me that that terrible sore
has finally been lanced and that it's
meant that although there are some
people who just want to replay 2016
forever by and large people have now
progressed through the various stages of
grief and that while there were people
who were stuck on the second or third
stage you know they were still
bargaining they were still pleading I
know the people voted to leave EU but
perhaps we can beg them not to or get it
back or by and large those people have
passed through the stages of grief now
and have realised that we've got to make
the best job of where we are whether you
were falling
or or four remain and so so so in a
better position on that and I just had
one thing which is that throughout this
coronavirus it is striking to me that
there has been much more public support
and unanimity for the government's that
starts here because it's Boris Johnson I
mean I can assure you as a fairly vocal
critic of Jeremy Corbyn who was the
Labour Party leader until earlier this
year if Jeremy Corbyn had won the
election in December and Jeremy Corbyn
and Diane Abbott his would have been his
home section had told me to confine
myself to my house and never leave again
I'm not sure I took grief to do it I
mean very suspicious of it I just
thought it was very personal about for
anything else but no III I don't think
that is I think there's reason why we
have a certain amount of trust in Boris
Johnson in a way that that in America
you know as I said he just have this
totally bifurcated still as this nation
still so I touched on him a little bit
earlier but I was wondering if maybe you
could explicate for for folks in the
United States or on the right side of
the aisle the difference is between sort
of British conservatism in America and
conservatism and American conservatism
there's been this real drive for smaller
government a more libertarian view of
society in in British conservatism what
are the animating forces behind British
conservatism that separate them on the
one hand from sort of the Labour Party
and on the other hand from American
conservatives the truth is is that in in
many ways British conservatives will be
seen as pretty left-wing by their
American counterparts and I've seen it
all my life I mean that there is a very
clear difference in in Drive between the
Republican Party for instance in the US
and the Conservative Party in the UK
part of it is tonal part of it goes back
to thing I mentioned at the beginning of
you know the Conservative Party having
for a long time made its peace with the
welfare state and IIIi think beyond that
there's a very interesting question
within British conservatism which is is
there much more than the economic
element of it and and that's something
which I think in the states in the stage
you could say yes and it's essentially
the defense the amendments and of the
Constitution and and some social issues
which you obviously like abortion go
round and round and fight very very hard
on in a way which I sort of in a way I'd
admire Meyer the fact that America still
takes certain very fundamental issues
very seriously in debate sincerity but
in in the UK we don't have those sorts
of issues you don't really have these
litmus test issues I think well that's I
think that that's a fear in many ways
and I've often had this conversation
with other conservatives and
conservative philosophers in the UK of
of what conservative thinking in the UK
really is because it has been hard in
recent decades through identify what it
is beyond a certain view of a state a
certain view of of the economy I'd say
this is this is a something that needs
to be addressed because conservatives
took conservatives took an awful lot for
granted in the UK um and and probably
have been reminded all of us in our
lifetimes of how unwise that is let me
give an example I mean we have a
monarchy in the UK and this is just part
of the fabric of the state now I would
say that it's obvious that the
conservative would inevitably be
defensive of the monarchy inevitably be
in favor of the monarchy but it isn't
something you hear people going on about
because it's sort of agreed upon it's
accepted there are some people who you
know want to get rid of the monarchy but
my point is is that we have great
institutions in the UK wonderful
institutions which have endured the test
of time and have provided as the Queen
has actually in particular recent weeks
extraordinary level of unity and and
really moral encouragement to the
country and but I mentioned that because
conservatives don't go on about it
because it's just in the fabric of the
nation and many of these institutions
many things that are conservative we've
just forgotten to talk
about and and you know I mentioned Roger
Scruton earlier it was a great friend
and a great inspiration to me and Roger
was always thinking about this why is it
that conservatives have so little to say
about for instance beauty the built
environment you know what does it matter
if you've got a Conservative government
in power if it's rec to the inner cities
of all of our beautiful cities and put
up horrible horrible monstrosity
buildings what I think it was Lord
Clarke our hearts father and Kenneth
Clarke Laurel Clark of civilization but
who said that if if you want to judge a
civilization you shouldn't you you
shouldn't read the speeches of the
Finance Minister you should look at what
buildings have directed that'll tell you
that'll tell you everything very very
fast and and I do think that there's
something in that what did it matter to
have post-war conservative governments
erecting huge tower blocks that they
expected the populace to live in and so
they're they're an awful lot of
questions which which we've just
presumed and a lot of a lot of these
presumptions have just been been allowed
to go by by conservatives in the belief
that well at least we've got control of
the economy and and after that that is
um that is something I think which
everybody on the right has to think
about more is is and mainly sorry I'm
going on it but let me just say one
thing mainly because it's so striking to
me that the left speaks at a totally
different level from the right on issue
after issue again this may not be the
case quite so much in the US but I'm
just so struck by the fact that the left
does something like inequality and the
right talks about the small increase in
house building in brownfield site areas
or something you say wow that's gonna
fire him up and and and again and again
on issue after issue that's what happens
in if the left talks to things that are
very deep are you often used to talk
about this with Roger with look at that
will look at resentment and look at
resentment envy those are deep deep
human instincts the play to
when the left does resentment and envy
if the ronique just says oh we found
this really interesting tax loophole
that we can address it's not that you're
not doing anything but you are not
acting at the same level if somebody
does resentment to you you need to do
something of equal weight back I would
argue on that one aspiration for
instance but you need to talk if
somebody else is talking about despair
you need to talk about hope you know you
need to counter these out and I think we
haven't done actually conservatism in mu
K has been in power but it's done a
horrible job so in just a second we're
going to talk about the royal family and
the European perspective on president
Trump if you want to hear Douglas
Murray's answers on those specific
questions head on over to Daley wire.com
slash subscribe and become a member he
can hear the rest of our conversation
over there Douglas Murray really
appreciate your time go check out
Douglass's books madness of crowds bells
the strange death of Europe Douglas stay
safe in there forever since none of us
were ever leaving our homes and and we
won't have to worry about the death of
civilization because literally we're
never going to see it again so that's
that's exciting stuff yeah well we
wouldn't notice it even if it went
anymore just yeah goodbye but it's been
a great pleasure Ben I'm very glad to be
able to do this and I hope to be able to
do it in person at some point sounds
great thanks so much
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike Joyner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer Katie Swinton
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex's
singhara editing is by Jim nickel audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia and Gullu the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]